he also has had a nice stretch run here
in his home ballpark now obviously this
year no fans but
he's been on a roll at home not so much
on the road but stephen mats is looking
to put together
really a strong campaign if they're
gonna have any chance
for the division and the playoffs
conforto giving chase and
stumbles what makes the catch for the
second house here's the ever dangerous
jd martinez
with two down and the base is empty
breaking ball tap left side this is a
tough play for mcneal
bare hand throws on the run throws it
away but getting over there is dozier to
back things up
now the question is did it go into the
stands i think it did and so jeff mcneal
has had a tough start
defensively that's his fourth error of
the year already
xander bogart's back in there
another tapper this time mats will do it
himself and
lonzo just keeping the toes on on the
stretch nice play pete alonzo
martin perez on the mound making his
second start of the year and martin
perez was signed to be
you know a little lower in the rotation
john but with everything that's got on
guess what he's the number two starter
and they need him right now they need
his hot first half start
he had for the twins doesn't let the
second pitch go by tough play now and
it's kind of in no man's land
and mcneil will stop that first come on
back so
jeff mcneal has himself a two out base
hit
and up comes jd davis now
missed the target but it worked out
anyway you go to the second from city
field no score red sox and met
catcher christian vasquez leading it off
and
he's off to a fine start
what's this one in the air this one is
high and deep to left davis going back
and it's gone
back-to-back knights with a home run for
christian vasquez and the red sox out in
front early
well right on cue he showed that power
middle to middle down
a change up that just stayed in the
middle of the plate
and when you're trying to work in your
change up the last thing you want to do
is give up a home run and then put it in
your back pocket
and hit deep in the count
and takes that one right down the middle
for strike three
2-2 is high and there goes the runner
throw down
is in time what a throw by vasquez
as conforto is gunned down made it look
easy
so just like that two down bases empty
and a full count to brian dozier
danny got him back-to-back strikeouts
looking for martine perez
payoff pitch one more time just missed
down low good eye ramos he draws a walk
and avali has been the one guy who's
been good as nimmo
hit by the pitch and he goes racing down
to first
runners on the corners ahead
three-and-oh does he take a rip
nope not even close and the bases are
loaded so perez with a walk
a hit batter and a walk to alonso and
the bases are loaded for jeff mcneal
2-2 on the way mcneal slices one for a
base hit
nemo scores rosario motoring around here
comes the throw home
it's offline a 2 rbi
single for the scratch golfer jeff
mcneil and the match take the lead
this is classic not trying to do too
much and like i said
alonso passed the baton on in good hands
and the third
inning in a row where the red sox have a
lead off runner reach
christian vasquez his turn now solo home
run
in the second inning so here's where you
can get confused as a pitcher
you just got o2 that quickly on two
fastballs one away
one that kind of tied him up there's no
real reason to waste a pitch right now
if you think you can get him
three in a row after he just took a
change up
off of you earlier for a home run
he listened to you fastball he might
take that one out
davis back to the track back to the wall
leaping up
a home run again for christian vasquez
so he got the change up earlier he got
the fastball that time
a two-run shot and the red sox are back
in front
2-2 and nimo late and throw down to
second
and the rudder is back but nimmo down on
strikes
on the fastball so two down as jimenez
will stay at second base
no hembree his second strikeout and now
one out away from getting out of the jam
zarya rosario got on a really good roll
against relief pitchers since the
all-star break of last year
tapper left side beau charging throws on
the run
in time in the end so now it's jd davis
oh for two with a walk
in the sixth inning looking to deliver
here
one two curve ball davis
[Applause]
[Music]
runners on the corners one out there's
cordell the pinch runner alonso the
tying run at third and it's michael
conforto will be the hitter
one more time payoff pitch
and he got him now hoping his teammate
suspenders
can tighten him up with a two out hit
eighth pitch of the at best
and he went fastball upstairs and it
just missed first fastball at the at-bat
cesspit is laid off and the bases are
loaded
two and one to jimenez nowhere to put
him for barnes
and to the right side
well edwin diaz has come on and he's got
himself in a lot of trouble
two walks and a base hit
comes in and he hits him and then comes
a run for boston
so brandon workman comes in for the
second straight night to try to close
out the mets
and that final out will not be easy it
is alonzo
workman 2-2 and he got him
and the red sox win it back-to-back
nights that brandon workman closes out
the mets
and the red sox come to new york and win
both